Nikki hailey has resigned as US
ambassador to the United Nations
prompting tears and panic among
conservatives who seem to have forgotten
that the UN does not matter at all we
will examine the unexpected resignation
then President Trump booths on justice
Cavanaugh's critics google continues to
hate America and the Washington Post
publishes the dumbest article on the
Internet today
finally Che Guevara is executed on this
wonderful day in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
these are some great days in history
lately we got Columbus Day yesterday che
guevara gets gets iced today that we're
really that's great before we I can get
to this breaking news
that nikki Haley is resigning we have
got to thank a wonderful sponsor pair of
thieves you know we've been talking a
lot about boudoir --is-- things recently
you know all this Cavanaugh circus let
me tell you about my underwear okay let
me tell you about my negligee I love
pair of thieves it is the best that I
have ever worn on average do you know
that men keep their underwear for seven
long years until they're a tattered
shell of what they once were don't be
that guy you don't want to have boxers
from when you're in high school or
something like that pair of thieves are
the most uh the most the most
comfortable underwear I've ever worn
hands down they have this proprietary
moisture wicking fabric that keeps you
cool and fresh like a c4 you know below
the waist it feels like you're wearing
nothing at all
very often I am wearing nothing at all
so pair of thieves fits in really well
with my typical repertoire it is
proprietary in this case all of the
competition has been trying to copy this
fabric for four years they have failed
here is the best pitch for these the
pair of thieves the guys who started
pair of thieves one of the guys says
that all his wife ever wants to see him
in is a pair of they're super fit briefs
do you know who that guy's wife is
Jessica Alba so now you've got
recommendations from Jessica Alba and
sweet little ELISA and sweet little Alba
that's pretty good try them out if
they're not instantly your favorite pair
of underwear if they are Jessica Alba's
favorite they will be your favorite
they'll give you your money back for a
limited time this month only our
listeners get 20% off their first order
at pair of thieves comm slash Noel's
canna wles get 20% off when you go to
Pai are oft hie ves comm /ko wles this
month only pair of thieves comm / Noel's
all right Nikki Haley has resigned she's
out at the UN people are rending their
garments gnashing their teeth I want to
make two points on this one nikki Haley
did an excellent job as the UN
ambassador
she's actually not officially out until
after the new year
so she'll continue to do a good job
presumably she did an excellent job as
UN ambassador the second point I want to
make I don't really care that she's
moving on I don't care I don't who I
mean it's the UN have we all forgotten
that the UN does not matter at all you
know two things can be true at once so
but let's focus on point one first she
really did do an excellent job she had
these great breakout moments here is one
right after the the UN have decided to
censure the United States for moving the
u.s. embassy and Israel to Jerusalem
here is Nikki Haley's response I think
it really summed up her entire tenure at
the United Nations unlike in some UN
member countries the United States
government is answerable to its people
as such we have an obligation to
acknowledge when our political and
financial capital is being poorly spent
we have an obligation to demand more for
our investment and if our investment
fails we have an obligation to spend our
resources in more productive ways the
United States will remember this day in
which it was singled out for attack in
the General Assembly for the very act of
exercising our right as a sovereign
nation we will remember it when we are
called upon to once again make the
world's largest contribution to the
United Nations and we will remember it
when so many countries come calling on
us as they so often do to pay even more
and to use our influence for their
benefit absolutely beautiful and it does
remind me of that pic clip of cocaine
Mitch from 2013 you know where he says
we will remember this and Democrats are
going to regret this in the near future
you know and like it's demonize open up
and he's like I'm gonna come coming for
you and the same thing with nikki Haley
here she's saying we're gonna remember
this when we set up foreign aid we're
gonna remember this when we continue to
be the lion's share contributor to the
United Nations we'll remember you
in gratitude but we frankly we don't
care what you have to say that was
beautiful beautiful stuff from Nikki
hailey now I must say I have had some
disagreements with ambassador Halley in
the past really only one I had this one
major disagreement with her she was
speaking at a conference for
turning-point USA this was what maybe
six months ago or something like that
Madeleine maybe a little bit less and
she spoke out against owning the libs
this way this was kind of the low point
I think in her tenure as UN ambassador
here is nikki Haley use your hand if
you've ever posted anything online to
quote-unquote own the lives I know it's
fun and that it can feel good but step
but step back and think about what
you're accomplishing when you do this
are you persuading anyone raise your
hand if you've ever done anything on the
Internet to own the lives raise your
hand if you've ever done a best-selling
blank book to under lips raise your hand
if most of what you think about when you
wake up in the morning is how you can on
the libs so yeah we have a disagreement
over this and the disagreement is mostly
stylistic but it is strategic as well
and I actually spoke in DC about a week
after this to give an answer to this
speech and the idea is she says that
you're not persuading anybody when
you're owning the libs but I think you
it really is persuasive when you on the
lips I think it's very persuasive
what is owning the lips owning the lips
is largely using humor and just
propelling your political agenda with
confidence and not getting bogged down
in all of the stupid criticisms from the
left
that's what owning the libs is it's
using humor to advance your political
agenda and it's not really caring when
the left shrieks and howls and moans I
think this is wonderful I think that is
leadership I think it is persuasive I
think the Trump administration the Trump
victory all the way up through this
Cavanagh confirmation it displays this
perfectly the great strategic advantage
of owning the libs and I think it's nice
it makes people like us more if we can
smile a little have a sense of humor
laugh
so that was an actual point of
disagreement on strategy but it
certainly didn't affect ambassador
Haley's performance at the United
Nations and I think maybe she just she
doesn't fully appreciate yet what owning
the libs can do you know it's a really
lovely thing to do but but that blind
spot aside she did a wonderful job at
the UN I'm glad she did it she basically
nailed it stuck the landing now she's
going to do something else that's fine
it it doesn't matter that she's leaving
I know you know we talk a lot in
politics how everybody is so reflexively
outraged this is the big problem on the
left and the right we're all reflexively
outraged role in the news cycle we're
all on Twitter the latest thing addicted
to outrage is the title of Glenn Beck's
book this is a good example to avoid
being addicted to outrage or shock or
horror or hysteria it does not matter
who the UN Ambassador is in this
administration it doesn't in this
because the White House sets the policy
sets our policy toward the United
Nations it sets our foreign policy so
the ambassador to the United Nations
needs to be a good face for America to
the world needs to be able to stare down
the worst people in the world okay all
great nikki Haley did that very well but
who's actually making the policy here
it's guys in the White House it's John
Bolton it's Mike Pompeo over at state
it's Dunford at the joint Joint Chiefs
of Staff
it's James Madison secretary those are
the guys who are actually making the
policy the UN Ambassador isn't really
doing that you know that the UN
Ambassador ship has gone back and forth
from being a cabinet level position for
decades now it is right now a cabinet
level position the only reason it was in
the first place is because Dwight
Eisenhower really liked Henry Cabot
Lodge and after John Kennedy beat out
Henry Cabot Lodge and I think it was
1950 was in 1952 I think was 52 he
decided to appoint him UN ambassador and
make it a cabinet level position just so
that Lodge could talk to the president
just so he wouldn't have to go through
the Department of State but it's gone
it's gone back and forth over the years
it remained a cabinet level position
through the Reagan administration George
Bush Senior demoted it and made it no
longer a cabinet level position which is
kind of funny because George Bush had
been the UN ambassador
for but he said there was no reason for
it to be a cabinet-level position
Bill Clinton then reinstated it as a
cabinet position George Bush demoted it
again and during Bush's tenure we had
the greatest UN Ambassador in American
history john bolton the current national
security adviser obama made it a
cabinet-level position again and donald
trump has maintained it as a
cabinet-level position interestingly to
john bolton who was the UN Ambassador
does not believe that this should be a
cabinet-level position because it's a
little awkward you shouldn't have two
people from the same department both at
cabinet-level positions Secretary of
State and the ambassador to the United
Nations so I agree with that I don't
think that the position matters at all I
think it's a glorified spokesman and
that's fine a lot of politics is being a
glorified spokesman but it doesn't mean
we need to worry and say oh gosh
everything's falling apart also I will
point out when people have left this
administration it's either the people
they've been replaced by are either just
as good or better have you noticed this
you know McMaster goes away and we get
John Bolton Tillerson goes away
television was pretty good and then we
got Mike Pompeo he's even better
the people who Reince Priebus goes away
and you get John Kelly John Kelly's been
an excellent chief of staff Sean Spicer
goes away you get Sarah Sanders I like
show us Bush I thought you're on Spicer
was good that Sarah Sanders was even
better so I do trust President Trump on
personnel matters broadly the Omarosa
sup the world aside I think he's done
very well in appointing people in
putting people in good positions and
being able to delegate to them and if
this was an amicable exit so if if they
stormed out and he said something mean
to Haley and she said you know I'm
running in 2020 that would be a disaster
that really would not be great at all
but that's not what happened
he tweeted out he said my friend nikki
Haley is you know going to leave now but
she can always come back we always want
her to come back she said that she needs
a break from politics and fair enough
maybe she maybe she doesn't need a break
from politics there there is a lot of
speculation as to why she left but I
will before we speculate before we go on
and try to figure out
what's gonna happen next who's coming up
next why she's leaving I do just want to
leave you with a very important point
from the current national security
adviser the former ambassador to the
United Nations John Bolton as to why
this is all going to be okay the point
that I want to leave with you in this
very brief presentation is where I start
is there is no United Nations there is
an international community that
occasionally can be led by the only real
power left in the world and that's the
United States when it suits our
interests and when we can get others to
go along Secretariat building in New
York has 38 stories
if you walk ten stories today it would
make a bit of difference the United
States makes the UN work like wants it
to work and that is exactly the way it
should be because the only questions
only questions the United States is what
can our national interest and you don't
like that I'm sorry that that is the
fact yeah get them my only question and
all this is if it's possible to
simultaneously serve as the National
Security Advisor and the ambassador to
the United Nations I am running the make
John Bolton UN Ambassador again campaign
or the MJB
UN AG man Juma bug that's not gonna look
as good on a hat but that's what I want
that would be terrific to round that out
good job nikki Haley excellent job job
well done we're gonna be okay now why
did she leave the timing is pretty weird
because typically if you're gonna have a
personnel change you would wait until
after the midterm elections look I'm not
saying this is gonna throw races in
Missouri or something like that but it
is a little weird politics is very
volatile any change can have a dynamic
effect especially a month or two before
an election so why is she leaving now
I'm not quite sure about that one would
think maybe it's because she's gonna run
for president she's gonna primary trump
this would be a very stupid idea I mean
this would be political suicide for her
she took the job in the first place -
you know shore up her bona fides among
the conservative base and
Trump supporters during the presidential
campaign nikki Haley was broadly never
Trump than she obviously she served very
well into a bleed during the
administration I don't think she's doing
that she said explicitly I am NOT
running in 2020 I look forward to
campaigning with President Trump in 2020
I really don't think that's what's going
on one theory is that she's going to
replace Lindsey Graham in the Senate and
Lindsey Graham is going to become the
Attorney General and replace Jeff
Sessions I also don't really believe
that I suppose that's more likely but I
don't really believe that whatsoever
because one why would Lindsey Graham
ever want that job Lindsey Graham is
living his best life now
cocaine Lindsey Lindsey Graham Bo
Unleashed in the Senate just just
excoriating his fellow members so I
don't think he's gonna do that why would
he leave that relative job security for
the apparent difficulties of working as
president Trump's Attorney General don't
really buy it and also why would Nick E
Haley want to be in the Senate she seems
to really enjoy executive roles governor
of South Carolina ambassador to the UN
has her little fiefdom there at the UN
so I don't really buy that one either
maybe it's the Kavanagh stuff this is I
don't know if it's likely but it's at
least plausible
the timing is sobered she waited until
just after Judge Cavanaugh was confirmed
and then she decided she's out it does
this have something to do with I am
woman hear me roar solidarity again I
don't really buy this because again the
majority of Americans wanted Kavanagh
confirmed after that an FBI
investigation certainly the majority of
conservatives Christine Ford's
allegations have fallen apart the other
ones have fallen apart too so I don't
know what Stan she's making it could be
politics they're a little too clever by
half which is resigning announcing your
resignation right at this time right
after Kavanagh and then not running
immediately and so later on you can
either say I resigned because of
Kavanagh or you can say I didn't resign
because of Kavanagh and either way you
get the benefit of the depth I suppose
that's possible in any case that would
allow her to go and just you know hang
out at home and chill on this
lines and that's perfectly fine she's
got a son she's you know she's worked
very hard it's very hard working in
these administration's and do I think
this is normal turnover not quite the
time he's too weird for that but she
might have other ambitions that she
doesn't need to jump on right now the
the final possibility is that she's just
being sidelined and this I think is
probably the most likely you've got some
very big personalities in the foreign
policy room you know madis john bolton
certainly Pompeo these are big
personalities who have distinct points
of view on certain crucial matters they
tend to butt up against nikki Haley to
clam Russia and you know America's
greater Greater and Lesser geopolitical
threats so perhaps it's just that her
views are being sidelined part of the UN
Ambassador role is to advise the
president if you've got a guy like John
Bolton in the room who's a former UN
Ambassador and has a very well thought
out and determined foreign policy plan
maybe there's just no place for her
there I don't know it could be that but
again I don't really care she did a good
job the circumstances of her exit don't
change that she did a good job the UN
continues not to matter whatsoever it
should be abolished demolished and
turned into waterfront condominiums on
the east side of Manhattan it's fine who
cares who is a very good work Nicky
we're gonna keep on telling the the rest
of the international community of the
worst people on earth Iran you know Iran
China Russia we're gonna continue to
tell them where they can stuff it and
this does bring up the question of who
will replace ambassador Hayley
unfortunately I don't think you can
serve simultaneously as NSA and
ambassador to the United Nations which
means probably we're gonna have to reach
somewhere else in the diplomatic corps
or from some you know political
supporter one name that has been floated
now is Richard Grinnell he is the
ambassador to Germany he seems like a
fairly likely candidate he has a few
things going for him he spent eight
years as a spokesman and as a political
appointee to the United Nations that is
the longest tenure of any US
pointy to the UN in history he's also
very close with John Bolton we know John
Bolton has the ear of the President and
John Bolton's former UN Ambassador so it
might be him he sounds like a pretty
good guy anybody who can get up there
and tell the United Nations and the
international community where to where
to stuff it is good by me nikki Haley
did a good job at that
I wish the next person a lot of luck and
I wish nikki Haley luck in whatever
she's gonna do next I would like to
spike the football one more time with
regard to Kavanagh I know I know we
haven't done it enough halfway we have
I've been doing it for like a week and a
half now I just but I just want mmm yep
still delicious so we're gonna spike it
again here is president Trump in a very
unconventional and extraordinary press
conference on the confirmation of red
Cavanaugh I would like to begin
tonight's proceeding differently than
perhaps any other event of such
magnitude on behalf of our nation I want
to apologize to Bret and the entire
Cavanaugh family for the terrible pain
and suffering you have been forced to
endure those who step forward to serve
our country deserve a fair and dignified
evaluation not a campaign of political
and personal destruction based on lies
and deception what happened to the
Cavanaugh a family violates every notion
of fairness decency and due process our
country a man or a woman must always be
presumed innocent unless and until
proven guilty bingo
absolutely right I mean you know a
lesser man a weaker president would go
out there and say I feel really bad for
the accusers and well we'll just see Pro
actually I think what a lot of
presidents would have done is
withdrawing the nomination probably and
oh well I don't know but this guy has a
moral clarity he really does I know how
insane that sounds
I know how unexpected that sounds he has
a moral clarity a gut-level moral
clarity the he look
look at the Columbus Day thing yesterday
does what does Donald Trump know about
Christopher Columbus probably not very
much
but he knows what counts he knows what
matters he was a great man who
discovered America and he was a good guy
and he's been unfairly maligned by
leftist revisionist activists historians
and we should celebrate him and to
oppose Christopher Columbus's to oppose
our own civilization and it's
anti-american and that's what all of
that stuff is about he knows that and he
knows that he should support Columbus on
this what does he know about half what
happened 36 years ago not very much but
what does Donald Trump know about BS
everything he knows a lot about it what
do you know you don't you don't BS a BS
sir I think that's the line you Donald
Trump knows that he can smell it when
when Christine Ford's storyline was
changing she was contradicting herself
she was exposed for lies that she had
said key details that have not only been
changed but changed in such a way that
they were unfalsifiable President Trump
a lot of Republicans and conservative
said oh well I don't know and I know I
believe and I'm pleased I don't know
don't make me answer and what if
President Trump - he said yeah that
story keeps changing no but we're
sticking by Brent and you should all
apologize to Brett absolutely right that
is a moral clarity and he he should have
done exactly what he did at that press
conference and say I would like to
apologize on behalf of the country for
what happened to you Brett and what
happened to your family totally right
how does he have the moral clarity is
what I want to know this is a guy who
has worked in pretty mucky industries
you know Network television reality TV
construction in New York casinos beauty
pageants politics pretty gross stuff so
how does he have this kind of moral
clarity you don't have it on everything
you know it's been a little a little
liberal when it comes to the ladies for
instance but he where it counts and
especially where it counts in his role
as president he's got it I think of it
as akin to the ability to skim a book
you know this is an important skill to
learn when you go to college because
especially if you're taking a lot of
classes or graduate level classes you're
gonna have an amount of reading that is
not possible to complete especially if
you want to go out and you know like go
go to beach week 2019 you know and just
go like boo thing and throw
ice cubes at bars you're not gonna have
time to read it all so one of the skills
that you have to learn is how to power
skim you need to be able to skim for the
information because you're gonna be
tested on the information you're gonna
be tested on what matters you have to be
able to like scan hundreds and hundreds
of pages per week or sometimes you know
200 pages or 300 pages in a day and
pluck out the information that matters I
think that's how President Trump sees
the world
I think he's constantly consuming
information they're always saying you
know that he just sits in his room and
watches Fox and Friends all morning yeah
maybe he does and he's consuming all of
that information filtering out the
nonsense and identifying what really
matters he's able to do that a time and
time again on key policy matters on
moving the u.s. embassy in Israel to
Jerusalem on how to deal with Isis on
how to deal with North Korea on how to
deal with a trade in China had to
renegotiate NAFTA he's been able to
identify things where we say oh
President Trump he's not an ideological
conservative he's never read Edmund
Burke or Michael Oakshott or Russell
Kirk or whatever he's never read these
books sure maybe he hasn't I know he's
read reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide I know that for a
fact because he blurbed it but he had I
don't know if he's read those other
books but he's able to identify what
matters the practical things that
matters that's a wonderful quality and a
president because you know I bet Barack
Obama has read all those books in fact
I'm almost certain of it and he's read
all of those books and he's learned
nothing from them
president Trump watches Fox and Friends
and he learned so much more than Barack
Obama ever learned that's fine fine by
me I really appreciate that you know
some people on the on the right also but
certainly on the left they criticized
Trump they criticized Cavanaugh because
they say oh well he's not behaving the
way I want him to oh we accused
Cavanaugh being a rapist and then he got
emotional oh he shouldn't do that you
know by the way that for that Sicilian
expression means I don't care some
people think it means a more vulgar
thing it means I don't care
Antonin Scalia spelled that out very
well before his death but that's what I
say to them that's what I say
for those of you who are listening I'm
scratching my four fingers underneath my
chin who cares and how dare you who are
you to say because Barack Obama sips his
Shepley with the pinky out he knows it
he knows he has all of the information
and he knows nothing President Trump I
don't know he just manages to pluck out
these things and have some moral clarity
it's a really refreshing
speaking of Brett Kavanaugh before we
get off this point there has been a cash
surge for Democrats
after the Cavanagh nomination that's the
headline at least actually both parties
have raised money on this but there's
been a cash surge according to you know
all of the mainstream media and one one
in particular stands out Kamala Harris
sent out one fundraising email for Heidi
Heitkamp who is an imperiled Democrat
running for Senate and with that one
email she raised four hundred thousand
dollars it was an anti Cavanaugh email
surest four hundred grand for Heitkamp
that is pretty impressive but you've got
to compare that with another number that
came out of this whole Kavanagh thing
which is that the more the Cavanaugh
thing dragged on the further behind
Heidi Heitkamp fell so that I think now
she's like twelve points behind or
something like that but she was able to
raise all that money what does that mean
it means that a small number of lefties
have been whipped up into a frenzy and
are giving money even as the candidate
is losing support overall what is that
about why is this where these small
number of lefties getting whipped up
into such a frenzy and giving so much
money it's because the left treats
politics like religion this is a form of
tithing for leftists giving money to
Heidi Heitkamp is a form of tithing it
may be a form of indulgence you hear
them on the Left all the time talk about
white privilege and male privilege in
maiya colpa Mia culpa mea Maxima culpa
I think it's an indulgence too to make
good for your sin of being a straight
white guy who knows that he's a guy or
whatever aspect of that you might
possess by giving to some imperiled
Democrat in running for Senate I see it
as religion and Hillary Clinton my what
is it third cousin-in-law once removed I
always forget which one she is third or
fourth cousin in law
removed she is underscoring this she
says she just came out and said you
can't be civil with a party that opposes
everything that you stand for that you
stand for it's always you know
rationalists in politics they're always
standing I'm standing for this they're
not doing anything they stand and
Hillary is standing but consider what
she said you can't be civil with these
people because they oppose everything
that we stand for is the Democratic
Party everything that Hillary Clinton
stands for yes actually yes it is but
that's very sad because I don't think
conservatives treat politics as
everything that we stand for I certainly
don't I mean I work in politics I love
politics I read a lot about politics but
I don't when I think about what I read
mostly read about religion when I'm
reading books but you know it at night
before bed or in the morning I'm usually
reading theology philosophy history I'm
not really reading about politics per se
I don't go to like crazy screaming
marches and rallies and where some
genitalia themed hat on my head on the
weekends I don't do that at all I go to
a cigar bar hang out with my friends or
something you know go to dinner parties
I don't I I think that's much more true
of conservatives conservatives have
other things going on but for the left
they treat it like religion so in this
case it's true if you were to treat
politics like religion than if you're a
member of the opposite party it's like
you're an infidel you're a jihadi you
know there's a your there's a crusade
that's being waged against you or that
you are waging against them
it's it's pretty pathetic and speaking
of religious leftism you see this all
the way at google google you know Google
used to have the saying don't be evil
and then they dropped that saying about
six months ago presumably because their
new one is just be evil don't do don't
be evil well now they're being able they
are coming out really strongly in an
anti-american fashion we'll get into
that in one second but before we do I've
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube and you have to stick around
because we are going to dismantle the
dumbest article on the internet today
which happens to be about us about The
Daily wire and about pod save America it
is so so stupid we will get to the
in a bit and then on this day in history
as Che Guevara is executed got to go to
daily wash calm why because you get me
you get the end replevin sure you get
the Ben Shapiro show you had to ask
questions in the mailbag you get to ask
questions in the conversation that will
be coming up soon none of that matters
you know what matters I mean really I'm
preaching to the choir right now because
if you don't have your leftist ears
tumblr right now you're already drowned
and I'm sorry may may the good lord have
mercy on your soul because you are
floating somewhere after the that
Cavanaugh confirmation for the rest of
you get another leftist ears tumblr I
don't know what to tell you you could
use idioms 2 or 3 these days go to daily
wire comm we'll be right back
you know I really want to talk about
this Google being evil story but more
than that I want to talk about how
stupid The Washington Post is today so
we're gonna have to save the Google
story for tomorrow sorry sometimes we
don't get to things it's an important
story we'll get to it but this you know
I like to focus on the dumbest article
on the Internet on any given day this
one takes the cake I woke up to this one
and lucky me it was about us it was
about been particularly and about the
Daily wire and about those Obama
flunkies at pod save America and I want
to go through this in depth I want to
take a deep dive into this stupid
article by a guy named Dan Zack because
I think it shows you what the fake news
is I want to analyze this line by line
because it's going to show you why the
Washington Post is fake news why they're
Liars why you can't trust that stupid
rag Pravda on the Potomac the Washington
Post because it's so insidious it's it's
actually a little bit subtle you might
miss it if you're not taken through it
so it's about it's about us and it's
about these pods save America guys if
you don't remember the pods say of
America guys here's just a little
refresher of their serious political
commentary what is going on really
they're super serious guys I mean
they're so serious they were t-shirts on
Chelsea Handler's show they're so
serious you know they use the f-word
because they're like really serious they
really mean it you know that's how you
know when people use the f-word a lot
that's how you they're really SuperDuper
serious so there are these guys I think
they're about 16 18 and 19 all Obama
alumni from that failed White House and
they're but they're so self
congratulatory this is the thing about
the left you know the left likes to have
the appearance of the thing but they
don't want have the essence of the thing
that's like these guys they're the main
one I forget his name but he's that
good-looking one he looks john is jon
favreau is his name he'd not the actor
but the political guy Jon Favreau he
looks like he should play a White House
in the West Wing like he is the guy who
would play a White House aide in the
West Wing unfortunately he's not the guy
who should be a West Wing aide because
he doesn't know anything and he
obviously the proof of the pudding is in
the tasting he worked for a failed
administration and he himself was a
flunky of that failed administration
that no longer has any legacy but but he
looks the part and that's always the
left I always look the part and he looks
like he's 12 years old I'm I don't know
how old he is I think you know I'm
probably younger than he is but I look
about 10 years older than he does so
anyway okay let's get to the let's get
to the article the title the battle in
your earbuds the bros of political
podcasting and their quest to reinvent
pundit REE by Dan Zack dan Zack a fake
news reporter okay so it begins Los
Angeles in a drab office building across
from a used-car lot in the San Fernando
Valley the hosts of the nation's most
popular conservative podcast Ben Shapiro
was preparing to interpret reality for
his listeners let's begin their drab
office building
Travie now you've you've actually seen
the inside of our building because
you've seen us on the cigar show would
you call that drab I don't know I've got
I have multiple tuxedos hanging in my
wardrobe right now we have a four
thousand cigar humidor replete with the
greatest cigars on earth full bar it's
pretty posh man is what I'm telling you
it's pretty posh this but you know the
so I don't a drab okay that's that's
what she says she says it's across from
a used-car lot it is a I don't want to
give away our location it it's across
the street from like a how would you
call these cars used it would be like
calling a 1940 patek philippe watch a
used watch it would be like that those
are the kind of cars you know la is a
car culture there are places that sell
very very nice classic beautiful vintage
cars here that so that's one way of
describing it or if you're a dishonest
Hackett the Washington Post you say it's
a used-car lot okay that's how they
begin it goes on these are one of those
days where you think maybe I should have
gone to Wall Street joked ben shapiro
glaring at a torrent of tweets on his
laptop
a cramped windowless studio just listen
to how these at the cramped windowless
studio virtually every studio is
windowless the reason for that is that
you need to soundproof studios
especially when you're doing podcast in
radio you dummy
so but I don't think he's dumb I think
he's trying to be insulting and he's
using something that is a truism yes my
virtually all studios are windowless
some of the big ones at Fox you know
they kind of deal with it and I have
these big thick windows but you know
virtually every other studio is
windowless okay the this news cycle is
when it cuts to another quote the
wildest thing since Trump winning said
John Favreau
the former speechwriter for Barack Obama
was just a few miles away from Shapiro
in an airy sunlit Hollywood office as he
too processed the day's news into
analysis and talking points for his own
podcast listeners on the liberal end of
the spectrum
so when Shapiro does it he's
interpreting reality when Favreau or
whatever whichever one that was does it
he is he's giving analysis in the airy
who the sunlit area office okay he says
it's in Hollywood so obviously they're
comparing the San Fernando Valley that's
supposed to be like bad and mucky to
Hollywood as someone who lives out here
all of the studios all the major studios
Disney ABC they're in the San Fernando
Valley
that's where the studios are Hollywood
is where homeless people are that is
they said with area sunlit okay moving
moving right along how much time do I
could go on this all day so that the
article continues of the crooked media
guys ben shapiro says now i just want to
point something out
whenever the washington post is talking
about pod save america and all those
people they refer to them as the crooked
media guys
but when washington post is talking
about us they only refer to ben shapiro
now the daily wire not to not to toot
our own horn here we get a lot of views
we get a lot of listens pretty big shows
even even from the broom closet here we
get a good amount of you certainly
andrew Clavin does the website does very
well the daily wire i mean daily where's
i think one of the biggest publishers on
facebook if not be
in its space okay so you got that and
then but they say no no that there's no
such thing as that it's just been
Shapiro
but the crooked media guys quick really
quick named me three crooked media guys
I can't do I couldn't do it i neva know
the one guy Jon Favreau I can remember
him because he's the name of an actor
that's why I can remember him okay so
that I actually just that fact alone
shows you tells you everything you need
to know about the Washington Post's take
here is it okay of the quick and media
guys Ben Shapiro says I disagree with
everything they say but I think they're
good at what they do
fair enough I mean if they're if what
they do is spout idiocy to their
frivolous audience then I think they're
very good at what they do I think
they're superb at what they do but a
very charitable take from been told that
a visiting journalist is seeing Shapiro
first Tommy Vietor
I guess he's one of the other guys says
please tell baby Steve ban and I say
hello yeah so look I'm all for making
insults obviously I've just been
insulting these guys the whole time but
they should be good insults so if he's
if either calling ben shapiro baby steve
Bannon
do they not they're not even Google Ben
but Bench and Steve Ben and hate each
other that's like the worst nickname you
could give to him you know the right is
much better at nicknames in the era of
Trump to begin with but it's just it's
not a good insult because it doesn't
have anything to do with reality there
are a lot of names that you could call
Ben I'm not going to do that because I
want to keep my job for the next two
weeks but but that isn't one of them it
goes on fans wearing friend of the pod
t-shirts crowd the front rows at live
events with the crooked guys who are
greeted like rock stars instead of the
political nerds that they are on liberal
college campuses lonely conservatives
draw strength from YouTube clips of
Shapiro dismantling progressive
arguments like a hunter field dressing
and elk are you kidding me so what does
he say say fans wearing friend of the
pod crowd the front rows of live events
with the crooked guys who are greeted
like rock stars
oh you mean live events like when we
pack that 4,000 seat house in Dallas for
the Ben Shapiro out live show is that
you mean live event or no maybe when we
did the same thing
in Arizona the next night is that what
your oh those no they don't mention
those live events instead of talking
about our massive sold-out live events
what they do is they say that lonely
conservatives on campuses or in their
bedrooms you know in the dark
downloading Shapiro videos on YouTube or
E everytime Ben goes to a school the
city shuts down it's so popular he had
to shut down Berkeley California six
hundred thousand dollars of security was
needed for all of the people that came
out you dishonest hacks but that also
goes on it says you know the guys at
crooked they're greeted like rock stars
instead of the political nerds that they
are to be a nerd you have to be smart
and educated that does not describe our
our compatriots over there or our
opposite of compatriots at crooked media
their show look say say what you will
about Benny till he talks very fast
again when you listen to his show you
get a lot of information when you listen
to pod save America you get a lot of
whiny profanity that's what you get
those that's if you want some whiny
profanity from guys who dress in really
tight jeans and wear t-shirts in public
and think that that's acceptable then
you go to pod save America if you want
information and commentary and analysis
you go to the Daily wire that's how it
works so okay go it goes on on his show
Shapiro reads ads from this is the best
one on his show Shapiro reads ads from a
sponsor that sells a three-month
emergency food supply plus seed packets
for when things finally go south pod
save America shells for a company that
delivers fresh ingredients to your
doorstep so that you can cook yourself a
single healthy meal lentils and quinoa
dressed in tahini perhaps as the world
burns so what they're saying is Ben has
you know some survivalist advertisers
and the pod save America has blue apron
we also have blue apron we have the same
sponsor you dishonest hacks we have
these same I virtually only eat blue
apron because they sponsor all of our
shows you freakin hacks it goes all so
like so what really what you're saying
is like if you were to write that
honestly you'd say Ben and and you know
dayley wire and pod save America
both have blue apron but the daily wire
has more advertisers yes they're better
shows okay yeah great cool I'm glad we
have more advertisers goes on Shapiro's
headquarters has the look of a think
tank and the feel of a refurbished
doctor's office a reproduction of
Washington Crossing the Delaware hangs
in the waiting area an issue of cigar
aficionado sits on a coffee table
yes that cigar aficionado sits on the
coffee table to exemplify the experience
of sitting next to your 4,000 cigar
humidor you're beautiful
mmm several lounges that you have in
your studio you hacks so that goes on
about 55 employees work for him under
the banner of forward publishing
producing his daily wire website and
three other podcasts all hosted by
conservative men we won't even we won't
even dare to mention Andrew Clavin and
Knowles and Walsh no those men okay I
would just like to point out first of
all pod save America we can we know that
podcast name any other crooked media
podcast quick do it really quick can't
can't do it okay I actually can because
I've listened to them a couple times one
is from Jon Lovitz gonna love it or
leave it I think that's it that's the
only one other one I can name apparently
they have like 10 podcasts that not a
soul listens to other than pod save
America and but they're all hosted by
men they're a couple a couple of the
little podcasts have a female host but
like I am Telling You not a soul listens
to these things I how many people work
at crooked media like ten people ten
people listen to these podcasts all of
the other ones are hosted by liberal men
so that on say they say all those other
ones are hosted by conservative men yeah
theirs are hosted by liberal men men
maybe I'm stretching it a little bit
maybe men I'm stretching the definition
a little bit it goes on whereas the
crooked podcasts are playful pondering
conversations shapiro
lectures sternly with sermons that paint
the world is black and white good versus
evil
his prevailing on-air tone is one of
scorn and disgust can we get a clip of
POD save America please literally the
most important election of our lifetime
ever more than a presidential election
at this point this is like the last call
for democracy because here's how the
Supreme Court thing shakes that this is
the end this is the last call for
America for democracy and that was
either one of the few Clips I could find
where he doesn't use profanity to
articulate the points that he isn't
making so sorry saying oh you know
Shapiro's doom and gloom but pod save
America they're all happy-go-lucky
except for when they say that democracy
is ending this is the most important
thing it's all falling apart we're all
going to hell in a handbasket give me a
break
also you know ben is a fairly serious
guy but doesn't he does like Bernie
Sanders impressions he's giggles halfway
through a lot of his shows you know I
was with him on election night in 2016
we had to do we just sat there the rest
of us in silence because he was giggling
for like 40 seconds when Trump won and
he said because he was the first
president Trump okay it goes on it's
working for him meaning been his podcast
was number eight overall for August pod
save America while the second most
downloaded news show on Apple podcasts
in 2017
didn't rank in the top twenty that month
let me interpret that for you let me
translate that for you Ben's show is
super popular and one of the biggest in
the country and pod save America isn't
that was what that's that's how that
sentence if this were an honest article
that's what that sentence would have
read but unfortunately it's not an
honest article so they say but how do
they phrase it the positive America well
the second most downloaded new show on
Apple podcast in 2017 well while we're
citing irrelevant statistics what is the
what is the airspeed velocity of an
unladen swallow what is that
you know pod save America while the
airspeed velocity of an unladen swallow
in 2017 would it didn't rank in the top
twenty that month yeah right it didn't
right it's not that popular exactly and
we're much more popular cool I bet you'd
give the stats for the other shows too
by the way compare the other shows at
The Daily wire to the other shows at
crooked media I have a feeling that the
Washington Post will be surprised they
actually won't be surprised they know
the answer to that they're just they're
just trying to be dishonest really
pathetic but really fun to go through
anyway thanks a lot Washington Post for
exposing yourself for the lying acts
that you are I hope you're watching my
know your watch
my show I know you're watching Dan's
a-kor what's his name is it Dan sack
Dan's act right yeah okay Dan Zach Dan
Zach jon favreau I'm learning a lot of
new names today okay we got five seconds
left so I'm just gonna wrap up with this
really quickly Che Guevara was killed on
this day in history normally I would
skip it since we're running this late
but I don't want to skip such a
wonderful occasion as this in 1967
us-backed bolivian forces captured the
cuban communist revolutionary Che
Guevara and he executed him then they
cut off his hands as proof that they
killed him and then they buried him in
an unmarked grave
unfortunately this treatment was a
little too nice for Guevara this was a
little better than Guevara deserved but
whatever that's what happened and then
he was dead che Guevara he's the guy
who's on the t-shirts that lefty useful
idiots where to apologize for slavery
and communism he is this he was born as
a rich kid in Argentina's family had a
lot of money he was born in 1928 he met
Fidel Castro in the 1950s and overthrew
the Cuban government and turned that
island into a slave state that destroyed
the lives of countless people over 50 60
70 years he's also a psychopath and an
idiot Che Guevara I got to see some of
his journals when I was in Cuba last
year they do not reflect a great mind
but on the psychopathy he wrote in his
diary the situation was uncomfortable
for the people and for you t mio so I
ended the problem giving him a shot with
a thirty two millimeter pistol in the
right side of the thirty-two pistol on
the right side of the brain with exit
orifice in the right temporal he gasped
a little while and then he was dead you
really like to go into that detail
didn't he because he was a psychopath
it's estimated they killed hundreds of
unarmed civilians during his life he
enslaved an entire island and now useful
idiots where his face on a t-shirt but
we got him 1967 on this day in history a
beautiful day to celebrate that's our
show come back tomorrow oh I'm gonna be
hosting that radio show again on Katie
th today so I'll be on the air for three
hours I think that subscribers will get
to watch that on the website sub that'll
be fun if you want if you want three
more hours
little ol me otherwise you can listen if
you're in the Pacific Northwest Katie th
770 and if I don't see you there I'll
see you tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you